winter is coming and a lot fewer people
are going to be alive to see it Game of
Thrones season 6 episode 9 battle of the
bastards this is your reminder i do not
do spoiler free anymore now i am going
to be nitpicky on this a little bit so
let me start by making clear i really
enjoyed this i thought it was a very
good episode on a lot of levels however
HBO i think miss marketed this because
the way the marketing was with all the
focus being on battle they really made
it look like this was gonna be something
like the battle at Blackwater or the
assault on the wall an episode was gonna
be nothing but the battle and it's not
actually the battle doesn't really get
going for quite a while that's not
necessarily a bad thing in and of itself
and again I think the episode is really
good but I think that was a marketing
mistake it didn't bother me too much
because well I get HBO now so I didn't
get to watch the thing for quite a while
and I heard from some friend of mine who
was watching it that the battle did take
a while to get going so i was actually
prepped on that but i can imagine that
if i was sitting there you know if i
came in going yay battle and it takes as
long as it takes for it to get going
yeah that probably would have bugged me
but as I said I kind of got prepped on
it the way that it does open I love that
opening I love Tyrion trying to save
face cuz the thing is he's not just
saying these things to the nares two
covers but he actually was doing a
pretty good job under the circumstances
she just came back at the point when
things were we're not great and then
you've got that face down between the
Masters and Daenerys and Tyrion and all
of them and just when she turn around
was like no we're discussing your
surrender I just got the biggest grin of
my face is like and here we go dragons
and the insulators on I'll of grey worm
just telling their people like are you
gonna die for these people who won't die
for you cuz this is your chance to just
go home right now and of course Tyrion
laying some great Smackdown he does it
twice in the episode cuz he he really
throws it at Theon to and wealthy house
taking a beating he was really a jerk
back last time Tyrion somme so you know
what it's fair and I love
yarra and Danny together I you know what
I don't really I don't do the
relationship thing the shipping for
shows but yeah I'll shipyard and Danny
back yeah but really the whole front
section or everything that happened that
marine really felt like well it felt
like the show finally going okay we're
done here we're ready to get across that
see finally finally 50 I swear to God if
they stall her again after this I'm just
got I I'll be bald when I come back and
do another because I will have pulled
all my hair up and then of course we got
the battle this was a serious battle
this would you know what this reminded
me of Braveheart that and which is
pretty much the high water mark for
medieval combat de patient as far as I'm
concerned and yeah they headed it was
harsh it was brutal and you know what i
figured recon was gonna die yet cuz i
was i was with sands on that is like
there's no way he lets him live the show
tried to go against expectations cuz you
know generally rule of three you thought
if he's gonna kill him that third shots
gonna get him any mess and I'm like nah
well actually you know I actually had a
split second where I thought oh my God
he's just trying to draw John out so he
can hit John with the arrow not that I
thought that John was gonna die but that
struck me as something that Ramsey would
have done it actually would have been a
really smart thing if he done it but you
know he's the psychotic you know Ramsey
is Ramsey is the Joker of Westeros which
I actually had that thought during the
episode and it made the way that he died
at the hands of his dogs just bringing
very very true and very nice even more
so than it did inherently because I
thought of the dark knight and the
Joker's whole thing how about I cut you
into little pieces to feed you to your
pooches i'll show you how loyal a hungry
dog is i'm not gonna say that i called
it that Sansa was gonna cut me she
didn't kill him personally but she
witnessed and though they don't didn't
show it for my money she picked that
means of death for him but I did I asked
and I received on that I wanted her to
be involved in his death she was yes I
mean I'm not gonna go through beat for
beat on that whole battle it was a great
battle although it you know when John
was getting buried and trampled that
they they kind of overplayed it he got
really it got really strobing got to the
point of my I'm glad I don't have
epilepsy they should have put a warning
at the front of this thing and you know
when they first are doing
it worked in terms of giving the
impression of you know what John was
going through just being buried under
bodies or and people crawling and
screaming he's not really seen what's
going on sir but I got the effect about
a third of the way into how long that
effect was done and like please stop the
show did a really good way of just
showing the battle just going south and
you know what San si was right Ramsay
play John and got him to do exactly what
he wanted any would have won and when
Littlefinger showed up I had two
feelings yes John and and the people
still around are gonna live and no no
little fingers tied up in all this crap
ah that guy plays the game well well
sorry to see the giant go I feel like II
didn't take as much but in the battle as
I would like he k he entered the fray
Greg just running and smacking a horse
aside but then it was kind of Spears uh
arrows down I mean yeah you did his
party was good he was I thought I just I
don't know I expected something a little
more Wow from him didn't quite get it I
think they've wrapped up a number of
things really well and be really
interested to see where things go
forward I'm not expecting a big blowout
in the last episode I you know it's
gonna be the just tying up loose ends
isn't getting set up in place for the
next season pretty much which is the way
most last episodes of the seasons go not
every time but by and large that's what
tends to happen that's what I'm
expecting here you know this was do you
know what this was a good episode as I
said that the marketing might have built
it up not necessarily badly but maybe in
the wrong way but in any case I really
enjoy this what were your thoughts on
the battle of the bastards whatever they
were drop something down with comments
and let's talk about it don't forget to
Like subscribe check me out on Twitter
at council of geeks check out the
council geeks podcasts on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned